yes
well the status
of uh georgie and i after the tell-all
um i have some
new breaking news uh we are no longer
together
now i have a lot of questions
will you marry me
oh baby
yes some of the biggest news that came
out of this season was of course
georgie proposing once again to you
darcy
you know it was so sweet how he included
your daughters and then the look on his
face you could you can tell that there's
a lot of love there it was all in his
face but you took a minute to say yes or
at least that's how it came off so what
was going through your head in that
moment
in that moment i was just i was
surprised you know i mean we had talked
about you know possibly getting
re-engaged you know in conversations
that we've had um i just felt like we
needed more time you know with the kids
to bond more as a family to see what it
would feel like be like miami was going
well i was just concerned about
um you know
money things and um
you know i know we have love for each
other i think
just wanted it to be right and real and
you know authentic and you know yeah he
got emotional it was a long day and
you know we were living in the moment so
it was a beautiful moment i'm glad the
girls were a part of it as well
just a little worried about the money
you're spending i'll start working i'll
pay my credit well you mentioned
georgie's finances um and i couldn't
this is just an honest question i
couldn't help but wonder you know his
debt was a conversation this season but
when he proposed with that big ring
beautiful ring
i know you said you were in the moment
but
later on did you think like was this the
smartest decision
i mean you know obviously money is
always a factor in relationships and
stuff i have you know specific kind of
taste georgie knows my style obviously
you know it's a very much so of a darcy
kind of ring
um he knows i'm
always wearing large diamonds and stuff
like that so when he you know gave it to
me i was pleasantly surprised but i
wasn't trying to think about the money
aspect at that moment
um
you know where there's a will there's a
way i guess in a sense and
um
you know in the relationship
your money is a tough topic you know to
discuss but it definitely needs to be
discussed at some point you know to go
further in the relationship because
you know it's a big deal
you know i don't want to be
stuck with debt and stuff like that yeah
well stacy we know you want the best for
darcy
do you feel do you feel as if marrying
georgie is in darcy's best interest
yes well the status
of georgie and i after the tell-all um i
have some
new breaking news uh we are no longer
together
now i have a lot of
we are no longer together and it was a
decision
uh that i made personally for myself for
my daughters and i took a stand because
i felt like the relationship wasn't
moving in the right direction from that
point of being engaged which happened in
the summer mind you you know that's how
i was in winter time so there had been
some time and communication still wasn't
going well there was a lot of things
that just
weren't
where they should have been and i take
accountability where i do but i just
felt like for me i needed to just walk
away and once it left
my mind my body followed and
i just i hit my limit with him
is the door still open for him or are
you done you know if i continue to do
that it's just going to keep happening i
feel and i just i want to keep my heart
open for the right person i'm excited
for you know where i'm at
in life right now um you know
people have their moments people have to
grow and learn and
you know
i think
i'm here
to really just you know stay open and
stay authentic and real to who i am as a
person and
you know a wife
to eventually be you know to the right
person so you know i feel that um
you guys will see you know in in the
future like how that kind of plays out
but i i just
i'm excited i'm excited for
the next steps then
something i've been hearing about you
bro is not really cool money in the
socks credit card debt
okay well let's talk about michael
yeah
michael neither georgie nor florian were
feeling michael the first time they met
looking back at the situation now
what do you think how do you feel about
it
i
you know honestly yes [ __ ] should have
had georgie's back a little bit more but
i guess
we've known michael obviously a lot
longer people don't understand his
personality and when he came in hot he
wasn't trying to come in
to have like an ego it was more like
these are my twins my sisters like let's
get the party started let's talk let's
get down to business that's oh my gosh
wanted to get along with them and yeah
but they had a grudge yeah everybody was
in the sun all day they were tired
georgie was trying to cook and it's like
a new guy in our life and yeah
who's this guy kind of you know it's
like the battle of the ego yeah at that
point yeah and we were kind of sitting
there like
what were we gonna say in that moment
how are we gonna defend anybody because
we were like
the two twins stuck in the middle yeah
yeah three guys like
it was like very fiery and
you know i i did say a few times like
please georgie stop because he was
getting a little aggressive with his
voice but michael i felt like was coming
from like he was standing up for us
kind of point of view georgie was like
just trying to be standing up for
himself not really for the relationships
and we had talked about
being there for each other and i was
kind of like oh why is he going in so
deep about
you know
just very ego and fiery and i was just
like we stopped like it was it was
bothering me it was very tense and i
don't like confrontation like that at
all and i thought it was best just to
kind of zip it for the moment and then
deal with it later on
which happened but i ended up
apologizing to the next day
to say that i'm sorry i didn't really
have your back yeah and yeah
yeah and actually michael and florian
are good friends to this day so yeah you
know wow i just needed to get to know
him a little bit in his personality
style and he's just very outgoing and
very
you know just hey i'm here like let's
you know yeah yeah let's do this blue
hair georgie kept talking about the blue
hair yeah i thought that was rude i
don't think he said that was just very
rude he loves you know blue hair pink
hair whatever you know he's always had
amazing style and uh we love to wear his
fashions as well and he unless we're our
like cool house eleven house
yeah very just amazing full of energy
and
you know
she's like a brother tomorrow yeah for
sure for sure well what are your
thoughts darcy on fans reaction to you
putting georgie in the mesh top his look
in the face
it's a fashion show in miami for swim
week if fashion shows tends to be a
little bit more eclectic you can do fun
designs it's not going to be a shirt we
actually sell some of the stuff that we
have is for you know fun patterns that
we don't have to walk down the runway
bedazzled or sparkly or whatever so
listen it hit him he actually likes it
in the moment so i wasn't gonna put him
in something that he didn't want to wear
but we had some options that he could
choose from and
he he liked it he actually liked it
yeah well
fans including myself we love watching
annika and aspen they bring a fun loving
element to the show
you know annika had her pageant which
she did great
aspen she moved past her i guess fear of
walking down the runway
confidence how does it feel to see your
daughters and your nieces
be this vulnerable but yet confident and
just genuine on tv at their age because
that's not they're they're very they're
very they're good girls and you can tell
yeah yeah they are amazing girls
they're so smart that you know great
heads on their shoulders and you know
you know during vulnerable moments they
want to show their confidence i mean i
think that
you know they're learning from their
moms and you know they just
just like we want to make them proud
they want to make us proud and i just
was just happy that they were in that
moment
to do whatever they wanted to do aspen
stream was always to be a runway model
she still wants to do that i mean they
both have what it takes to do whatever
they set their hearts to so i was really
excited for them you know once they
walked their nerves went away they had
fun it was like a blast like there was
no pressure
we just have fun
you know
walk however you want to walk it's all
good you know it's our show it's your
show
if anything i feel like you've seen
those girls walk down the runway and
showing their grace and elegance and
you know confidence yeah that was all
worth it in the end yeah it was a good
day that's a good day
okay well let's get into the tell-all
before i let you go there will be a
two-part tell-all this season first ever
for the series hey babe i don't want to
be there today with other people
i don't like any man talking to my
daughters like that any man what can we
expect what can you see tell us
you guys are gonna be so excited because
it's the very first tell-all first
spin-off um we're really excited to be a
part of that and we really like to all
let me tell you oh yeah um
you know there's gonna be some shows
there's gonna be some no-shows
doors going walk out walkouts there's
going to be some dramatic fiery moments
between some people that um are in
america i saw a clip of jesse jesse
he's just popping up like a weasel
everywhere i don't know how he popped
right he's popped up but he got put in
his place i'll just say that okay
i won't tell you by pluto but a couple a
few people yeah what was your reaction
when you found out that there was going
to be a tell-all what went behind that
decision
yeah we were really excited that they
offered us to tell all especially a
two-part tell-all i mean i've done them
that's a long yeah that's a lot a long
time yeah we were there um for a while
but you know what all of it needed to
come out everything needed to be
discussed and talked about i thought
that it was a great decision on you know
the network is very healing i was very
healing
we're all very authentic about it uh
really excited the only thing is you
know georgie had some hesitation and for
a while it was like like pulling teeth
just to see like you know
why he wanted or not wanted to be a part
of it um so there was a lot of
controversy about that behind the scenes
but the network was really excited to do
it and we were all for it we were really
excited and wanted to give our all
and tell all that's right
[Music]